all right I'm gonna enter this Terror style get
ready for it citizens of the reject Nation we
are here today I'm I'm Greg Al say say your
name on cam what's your name he's trying to
play me right now and I can see right through
it I'm Tara Ericson you're terara ericon oh we
are watching Haunted Mansion today oh my God I I
love Haunted Mansion at Disneyland I go on that
ride I left to get spooky season do you like do
you like Haunted Mansion Terra this is not a bad
impression of me yes I love that ride and I
should have worn my haunted mansion t-shirt
you guys know how I feel about Disneyland I'm
an annual passholder oh annual passholders are
great okay you guys know what to do okay leave
a like leave a like that's the first thing you
got to do say something nice in the comments for
us afterwards and also don't forget to ring the
bell ring the bell I thought it was going to
be Harmony it wasn't go it wasn't Harmony Greg
do an intro like terara and don't forget super
sexy reges you could be super sexy too if you
just go to our patreon page that's where you get
the full length Reaction watch that's where you
sink you sink you sink up with your own copy of of
haunted match we watching this on Disney plus you
have Disney you get Disney plus we get we all get
Disney plus so sink up with us watch along with us
all right are you ready to do this Terra this is
that was good five stars all right let's let's do
this welcome foolish Mortals cool to New
Orleans a most paranormal place where death
is not an ending But A New Beginning Amen to
that grief can be a doorway to Joy if one is
willing to walk through it grief can also be a
doorway to getting attention don't forget guys
that's true P.S my mom died cool that was a
attention thing oh I feel terrible for you
yeah thanks you can have more then you won't
have any that's fine not drinking much maybe
we could share it yeah make him drink first
just for safety what is it that you do um I'm
an astrophysicist [Music] boring I'm currently
working on a formula to map Dark Matter by
combining the structures we already have in place
with the what we're learning from Quant mechanics
and she's already sleep inside buddy trying
to see the Unseen o i you're seeing ghosts
get it girl I kind of do the same thing I give
ghost tours oh so you don't do the same thing at
all not all when science and Supernatural
meat she does the cooler thing Alysa Ben
[Music] Ben Ben oh my God I think I know
what happened I think she died and he's
trying to going to try to connect with her here
that's Jo Koy Filipino poo Pride are you still
leading her tour look I can sneak you out the b
Oh They'll follow me so it looks like we have a
John paluso president been an accountant for
almost 50 years oh I don't care I've been in
every haunted house in the most haunted city
in the world I've even been in that building
72 hours you want to know what I found nada
nothing not a thing ghost don't exist life
is dirt we're all dirt oh homeboy broken I think
you were right cuz the bartend said why are you
still leading her tour so I think you might have
been right that she is no longer with us maybe
this is how he'll become a Believer through
by the end of this that ghosts are [Music]
real it's right I remember I remember
her and ow Wilson was in this Danny
deito damn the castle is in this
this awesome Rosario Dawson it's a
Loki and Ahsoka crossover hello Jam
Le Curtis Curtis what is this cast
hey it's the movers yeah we're here
how close are you I actually even like
the way the credits are done with The
Apparition appearing like ghost credits
yeah wa cool pull Focus that feels exactly like
what happens on the ride did you see that thing
in the mirror I sure did wow you want to pick
out your room this kid's great upstairs love it
no cool that looks like a mouth that
looks like a an open mouth that bed is
awesome it's Sally The Bride not today
I think Sally's from uh remember Before
Christmas oh yeah maybe well there's
a what is her name the bride and the
haunted man and I forget her name
right now but she's the one at the
end that's a fun play on like Go sheet yeah
oh she's gone cool awesome cool w that looks
awesome pumpkin what's wrong this place is haunted
I love this kid hey I'm going to light a vanilla
candle and it's going to be a game changer will
it though oh my God's this kid he's funny so
good no we're
out
oh what a great transition shot there to
follow behind tracking that way safy first
slow slow you got this you got this oh my God
are the graveyard guys a that's like the ride
we they're in the buggy I feel like I'm just going
to keep screaming that's like the ride you'll be
back yes oh it's even keeping that Spirit of
like a period piece that is awwesome love it
I hope it maintains this Vibe no the treasures
I seek are in heaven what kind of psychopath
just enter someone's house huh I'm sorry
a trusting white man father km by the way
you want to be a hero pass you ready to have your
mind blown goodbye two words spectral photography
interesting gets to his Science Background
there's no such thing as ghosts then what's
the harm in just you drive an hour north you
snap a few pics with the Ghost Camera am not
driving an hour anywhere to hey yeah $2,000 there
we are whoa my job is having faith I got faith
in you I don't know he seems like a fraud huh
yeah he's got an ulterior motive [Music] maybe
the Ghost Camera you know how you and I are
so different but when we come together it's
really good agreed well this is like a bridge from
what you do to what I do right so look I got this
clever clever man it's a lens oh never mind
I thought he was misleading her Quantum lens
which if everything works how it's supposed
to it'll change our lives what happened you
think she died on a hunt never snapped a
picture of a ghost and she died of a broken
heart of course dead battery oh come on you didn't
charge that battery prior you can leave oh no no
no yeah you should leave if you want to leave
you can leave it's fine Gabby I'm not afraid of
a couple ghosts you say that now why why'd you
return yeah once you come inside like that's
it there is no no going back I guess it's just a
risk I'm willing to take now about the money uh
well cuz there's no going back maybe somehow she
was all right damn you did not have to give me
this much money I mean I don't even know if I can
take this no take it I insist okay okay I'm taking
it that was great
hey come on Ben you got to feel some of that
energy okay well that's my son ah the haunted
heads in the back I love them yeah well um his
father died oh oh hey pumpkin um hey buddy do
you want to come out and and meet Mr Maas
Ben this could be your new family maybe we
start in the dining room with the photos H
oh oh my God it's a physical representation
of the favorite room I love looking down on
that room I love it checked in here for go
touch him don't touch him nothing you take a
photo photo right what I'm here for the dead
battery ah normally it will turn its head and
follow you it's absolutely
terrifying it is I mean I'm
frazzled I love how he's actually
making this sound with his
mouth sometimes he's changing it every sharp pain
on both of my sides and I Walk This Way o cool
framing okay that's fun how it just switched
into like handheld when it was moving
her oh there going to be a fun history
here there are some great shots in
this movie mhm I love the lighting too
everything has like a sense of blue in
there did you not notice that man come on buddy
that was a ghost in the buggy you got did he
take a ghost back with him maybe they travel
oh maybe that's why the uh they actually ended
up back in the house cuz it takes you back
somehow not done blowing here so we're going
to get started oh is it the one from the painting
The Fisherman one oh as we'll find out these orbs
supposedly all right she said
once you come in you can't go back
okay now we get the battery
going I love his performance it's really
[Music] engaging that's awesome it
worked oh that's the
lady oh
oh
yeah oh it is SE guy awesome
oh whoa this really feels like a great movie for
like familyfriendly horror yeah that was an
awesome [Music] shot what is happening like
F what are you following me
oh maybe these Spirits need
help damn
whoa oh that's why oh does it
just take him all the way back
I think that forces you to return yeah right on
time it's a cruel trick lady they forced us
to come back here much like you what would
you could have done it spoken to me like an
adult and told me that I could never go home
again oh no but you wouldn't have believed
she did warn you come in you can't go back
it's not like you would have believed her right
you need an exorcist we tried that same thing
happened to me oh my God Ben welcome we're
going to fight whether we like it or not I
feel like sometimes you're focusing a little on
the negative yeah uh cuz we're never going to go
home again see that's a downer AR kept wanting
us to return yeah they want to be released if
they want us here I'm going to find out why
you're not supposed to leave after midnight
you're breaking the rules stop dude he's
a rule breaker your stubbornness is going
to get you hurt just like the ride sorry we have
become Leonard DiCaprio from Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood take it did I frighten you he's going to
be so excited you're here he loves yes whoa oh my
God are are you okay we're going to need more help
yeah you need to get more souls trapped here first
thing we need to do is figure out what happened in
this house there's a professor at T Lane who wrote
a book on haunted mansions in Louisiana only sold
about nine copies but hey he's not dead D Vito
yes well we're going to need someone who can
talk to these ghosts psychic she's been doing
readings at bar mitzz but gets a very solid
Yelp score oh no way ah have you recently met
someone named Gary you're very good that no
I did know a cousin Gary in my neighborhood
thank you have you met someone named Gabby she
was just deciphering all right got to be home
before God those boys chasing oh they were just
running me home they were just running me home so
great yeah I try to get a read on the ghost but
it's hard because they just won't stop moving
they're not just moving I I know this feeling
they're running from something yeah exactly oh
they have an enemy in their midst and they need
help the ghosts are also trapped in there with
something mevolent William Gracie he purchased
it from a previously undisclosed owner his wife
died of yellow fever that's when things started
to get weird isn't this great I mean I've been
dying a okay I got to see this I'm having heart
surgery next week you you cannot go need to come
I've got a car do not come then I guess you don't
need these all right oh my God you my prediction
Danny deito will die and become a ghost of the
house R what okay start the car hey help help so
strong ah a group of mediums went into the
house they were all found how old are you
nine okay I'm talking organs on on the outside
n is Young nine is Young they were a group of
amateurs I am a professional certified and
I can get rid of what died oh nicely said
bye-bye ni meeting you oh she might be fine cuz
she didn't you didn't tell me that these ghosts
be following people now I've decided to be the
bigger person and help you mostly because you
have left me no other options so tell me what
happened in this house there's a strange energy
to some of the Rhythm in the dialogue though
these papers say what happened in this house
Wier Gracie lost his mind and took his own life
sooth by poison Two Brothers shot each other in
a duel those paintings were wife chopped up five
of her husbands wow Constance is her name what
was the medium's name Madam leoto I think
letter from William Gracie to Madam leoto
asking her to come to his is Seance room but we
don't have a seance room you sure wait that's
the girl in the crystal ball right nothing
here it's hold it I got it is it a secret
doorway fun play on that trip
there oh [Music] cool damn good
eye
okay whoa neat cool it's fun that
it does feel like a Disney set in
like a very complimentary way yeah
maybe I'll just do a little blessing
of prayer to get us started on the
right foot God give us a break break
we that little music Cube felt very Disney
like she sleep look no no no she's she's in a
trans it's a s wait is sheep is sheep do this
awesome he's with
us talk
to Constance who's it going to say talk
to Leota Le can you contact someone for
me oh here just waiting for it my wife
you were The Grieving Spirit there's a
lot of really good symmetry in
a lot of these things oh we did
actually propose there yeah I can't I
don't think she's here what good are
you uhoh oh that's an angry
ghost what does this feel like
Madness that's the ghost I would be
just a mad this one no oh no Madam Le
Madam oh it's like the Haunted Mansion the ride
yeah that's awesome I didn't even realize what
they were doing so smart yeah what who
or is she at least being let free but
why cuz she's a threat who is that that
D yeah ah I love [Music] it feel my Stu
I will see this house and nothing's going to stop
me out he
goes whoa is he going further
yeah what [Music] [Applause] I'm curious
why a man his age was riding a chair likes
to ride chairs yeah it's his
thing I don't like the chair
okay okay and no more excitement for next
time at my is that what that's awesome
know I mean they can't leave him he's haunted now
all right and the place where they overlap most is
where the living can encounter the dead through
hauntings but when a soul passes and goes over
into the region Beyond if it's at peace that's
where it staying so it is a good thing I will
randomly hear a train off in a distance and I
know that's my dad saying hi a so sweet that's
a pleasant sign I like what hadish gets in sinere
that was a nice tender scene I love it I just feel
I know you already you see we have a friend in
common who is that voice don't fall for a [Music]
man awesome I wouldn't go in
[Music] there yes take us with you we we know
you're heading that way soon Alissa makeup
Alissa whoa Bruce disappeared and something's
happening all right going after like the fun
traditional haunting stuff uh hello that's a
painting from the ride I know everything is
from the ride but like cool is he going
to disappear from the painting like the
ride you called it you called it good
[Music] catch it's a great angle
they managed to interweave all
the ride stuff in a way that feels
seamless with the story yes and it
doesn't feel overly forced it just
is like yeah it actually and easy
yeah it's a clue
[Music]
man oh that was an awesome shot he
Hey Hey Hey listen I'm sure those
guys deserve what they got but baby baby
listen I call you ghost baby but me I'm
different I'm a I'm an ally to you
and always constantly having none of
that bab property of Madame Leota do not
turn another page [__] let's go hey oh
my God this is Madame leota's personal
book of incantations oh my God one of us
had to do don't come yes he's in the
ball in the C the ball is this worth
anything hey cool awesome oh is that jam Lee
that must be right how did you get in there
I can show you what happens but it will cost
you how much $3 what Ty robbery fine fine sh go
ahead William Gracie lost in grief sought
me out to contact his deceased wife wow
seriously the production design is Top Notch
yeah and the costumes are a killer it's time
to respond open a bridge to the region Beyond
she sounds just like her I love it the repea
it seances opened the floodgates of
the ghost realm hundreds of spirits
freely oh we had summoned a terrible evil who
fed on Gracie's grief he had the power to trap
these once happy souls in this house that's like
a demonic entity oh is this where she gets trapped
inside the yeah oh trapped me in my own crystal
ball who knows how long probably months now yep
yep he has trapped 933 Souls but he needs 1,000
to complete the ritual that will let him escape
this house I love how unaware she is at the
passage of time yeah it's $3 here for months
now not on our watch we got you but what are you
going to do they're already dead you're going to
be dead I love how O Wilson becomes progressively
less more disinterested four lack of days go Time
movie goes on a banishment but it requires an
object the spirit once possessed once you have
that enough oh boy there's been 66 deaths in this
house he's got 9.99 and unless one of you wants
to start funeral arrangements we better get out
of here I think you're going to be the next one
that scared me actually didn't Madam Leota say
something about needing an object they possess
now there is something very special that I can
do is quite oh my God these ghosts are annoying
pick the shells out it's fine you make crunchy
scrambled in I mean she'd be a grieving Spirit
too because because her husband yeah you know
I thought they coming down here we could put
everything that we went through with his father
behind us you know he could run around be a kid
en Joy but this house just won't let that
happen going to fall off that stupid break
his leg Travis hey Travis hey let him be a
kid I go talk to him okay just don't egg him
on exactly mhm they got egg jokes a brewing in
here you mean the cooking yeah I mean in their
heart talk to my dad today he wants me to come
visit but I think it would make my mom feel bad
I thought the dad was dead me too I think we
just assumed the dad was dead yeah and I guess
he's Fully Alive and still talks to his son
oh all right you got that all right all right
all right you won you won oh my God he could
be the daddy we knew that from the top Creek
open the door to your Dien but now my spirit
will enter the ghost real is it him oh here we
go
yes oh you're Lenor Gracie hey we need your help
you shouldn't be here like the
skeletal structure there yeah
whoa warps glitch 1 2 3 3 4 5 brother's d
a what great color schemes I like when he is
in this space it's all pink and normally back
down it's like a bluish this dark Spirit
who is he no one knows his mortal name
his power in this realm is beyond control
please you must not let him take the last
Soul or we'll all be trapped here forever need
more information yeah also the special effects
in this have not thrown me off at all they
look really really good yeah I know they're
amazing w w oh hell yeah
yes that's the guy his head
goes into the lamp for me
wait w that was awesome transition
but you you have promise you know
that life has no meaning that we all end up in the
dir there's the head in the lamp
I can give you what you want
go oh he's going toar argain for having the
soul of his wife oh wa holy junk that was that
was awesome there's no use offering is for
the weak and I know the way out damn these
transitions are great twisty turny it makes
me feel like doct Strange Land yeah W [Music]
awesome
whoa whoa you can get what you
want ah back to the reg that's great
that color change is awesome yeah I
know they had like amazing camera work
there and I love the way they mess with
the backgrounds the glitchiness my my wife
died in a car accident she liked to dance
she never she couldn't dance but she liked
to she also was the world's slowest runner
she That's my kind of Runner she said she was
going to go get some uh potato tops she liked
to take her top she has me to go with her I
couldn't do it cuz I was frustrated I had so
much work and so so many things I still had to do
so I uh so I went off she left apparently she uh
stopped off to get some ice cream she got into a
accident and about 20 minutes later she was gone
and that's why I put all my time and energy
dedicated to finishing the camera yeah yeah
seems like this is the first time we talked
about it look I don't know if any of us are
going to make it out of this aive I'll tell
you I wouldn't want to be going through this
with anyone else look at that he found friends
he's not so alone you said the image of his face
was burned into your brain yeah I have an idea
I think l stanfield's a very unique kind of a
leading actor but a leading actor nonetheless yes
what we would like is a sketch artist while it's
still fresh in his mind tall and hunch kind
of hunched over hey man eyes far apart close
average bit uh sunken into the recesses of his
ular sunk like a r they sit back his eyes were
doing that and no eyelids so they're into his
skull no eyelids what about his nose no nose
you know no no no no is this the man who mugged
you the police station paid off alist crunk very
bad man very bad son of cutthroat real estate
Tycoon Addison oh that's jalet cruel father
who kicked Alistair out of the house when he was
just a boy wow love this at his mother's funeral
said he needed to make him a tougher man this
looks like an old school graphic novel Alistair
returned a wealthy Tycoon who became famous for
throwing lavish parties with the very people who
betrayed him what a fascinating Choice never made
their way out oh that Alistair was embroiled in a
form of dark magic that required blood sacrifice
to maintain his wealth and power it's like jetto
in real life just before the axf Alistair
vowed revenge on all from Beyond the Grave
Crump a murderer in life I love the inclusion
of actual animation yeah fortunately for us
his old house was deemed a historical property
up a few hours North and turned into a bed and
breakfast bed and breakfast there you go come
on what's up with the p come on let's got to go
let's got to go it's they're doing it God they're
actually doing it that's amazing love it here we
go they managed to find ways to really include
this [__] in a clever way there's
always my way out TR look for a way
out oh my goodness this whole picture is
amazing that's great now hold on that alligator
is just a ghost alligator right so real though
uh-uh you better give it I reuke you there it
is there it is those teeth look really sharp
ining lady wow you are holding on seamlessly
looks like it's taking no strength to hold you
might want to give that ceiling a second
look one second Travis okay getting close
yeah I like how they the ghosts speak in like
in Clues oh finally look look it's kid oh kid
hey I go to my car for 5 minutes and then can't
get back in the house what happened beautiful
shot
oh this movie is at its best
when shit's just going wild yes
Bruce stay with
me oh [Music] man not only is this a lovely
bed and breakfast but the owners Pat and Vic
do dinner theater as well wait what became of
Danny DeVito he's dead with the Ghost with the
Headless ghost there's a tour starting in
5 minutes I want to go on a tour at this
place what is this place this tour will take
approximately 3 hours bathroom never mind I
don't want to go anymore you'll note there's
no seating in the foyer as he would have no
Mana rer go Winona Rider he had the legs
shortened and he added pillows to his seat
as to remain above everyone else so are those
his actual pillows no you just need one thing
M apparently they found crum's body but not the
head and the suspect walked out empty-handed so
people think the head is still here cool go
find it be fun they're going to become Head
Hunters Captain what is the purpose of this
what do you need maybe you help us and we'll
help you ask him where his head is no write your
message in the mirror whatever you want us to do
the SE the sea yes the SE we can do
that that's Owen Wilson right away
done oh they're bargaining never mind
okay what can you tell us about [Music]
chome ah this is going to be [Music] fun
oh great a dead end yeah come on you know
better than that into the fireplace we
go I can't fit in there yeah me neither
but you know who can come on buddy
you got to go down there you got to
go I'm glad we finally get some time with
him because I think he's hilarious and we
haven't heard from him in a minute yeah
I felt like the movie was going to be
way more about him and then kind of
I thought he was kind of a lead right
yeah this is where he hit all the bodies
a ghost going to pop up behind one of
them there it
is oh my God
man I hope everyone's okay I would have also
grabbed the head yeah just let me be a part
of this he just wants to be included Travis
is just too dang dous listen you made him go
down that chimney and go with all those ghosts
I'll try my dad okay see it I feel like is his
dad dead and he's caught like no never mind
I'm not even a priest yeah everyone wants to
think their house is haunted so I go sprinkle
some holy water and get paid I'm a fraud I'm
sorry that was the most obvious thing in
the world you helped me seeing myself that
I had something that was useful whatever
it is that we got to face we can't face
it without you let me ask you something you
want to be a hero n nice reversal I mean the
fact that you wouldn't know that he's not
a real priest after he goes God give us a
break Bruce you got to stop doing that possessed
where is everybody the house is clear it's over
Harriet found some mumbo jumbo in that book pay
attention to his voice God quite hary but the sh
struggle was necessary for character growth okay
so where's Harry and G uh why are you talking
like that that's uh come on sense falseness you
are a fraud yourself I'm going to go find them
oh and then they were two it's happy
hour somewhere right no no what a
turn of phrase H happy hour talk about overselling
it Dad I'm scared dad is dead okay that's what
I was going to say right before call his dad and
like bring his dad in the car and then I thought
I would sound dumb you have to understand guys
when T and I watch something together we're
bound to get confused by something everyone
else does not get confused by I got you
I got you I got you I got you give me
me he is surprisingly strong for a little
person no no what happens
now it's a full moon prump has
all his powers start the banish
me okay okay strange ADR choices in
this thank you for your assistance
Professor wa are 999 Souls that reside here but
there's always room for one more I like the blend
of CGI and makeup Travis is okay all right
he's at the car he's talking to his dad what
that that's not possible Gabby he still talks
to his father his father is dead Ben just over
a year I thought she'd clarify so even he was
confused oh my God okay so his dad is a ghost
yeah yeah yeah which I knew that but I'm like why
is here you have the most important job of them
all Kent you the diversion we're running out of
time come on K I have faith in you have faith in
[Music] yourself damn the vision jeels
really are the star of this movie
yeah time to divert what a fun house the only
chance we have to defeat him is combining our
might you must Release Me is it going to be a
positive thing this way with the Realms blending
we can find a faster route oh my God it's Harry
Potter Set Me Free and I will help you banish
him is this a good thing or are we setting her
up for a villainous sequel is that you Dad I'm
here is the dad a malevolent or benevolent I can't
tell me neither Travis Travis all right I need you
to give me your hand I'm going to see my dad
look I made a mistake okay I was wrong uh uh
I I can hear him TR who is that man they have
to be going willingly oh right no I I hate it
here I know but you and your mom are going to be
somewhere completely different than this I hate
it everywhere a this poor kid all right you come
here you tell me all about your misery we'll be
miserable together till there's nothing left trus
don't you miss me a you got it you got it don't
don't with me please come I like the messaging
of like the healing power of grief as well for
all eternity you and I make a deal all you have
to be is willing he has to be the Willing soul
and believe me I know a con when I see one in fact
this was all a con yeah this whole Chase was just
a diversion wow he's Ling about everything ask
yourself are you ready to be a hero [Music] oh wow
all going to leave them alone you're never
going to hunt them again ooh cool set take
my hand and you will be with your
[Music] belov oh the horse who you
imprison me now it's time to return the
favor pathetic see to them [Applause]
whoa they'll have to come through me first
and by me see means we everyone has banded
together oh no oh boy I've been convinced he's
going to die this whole movie when hinges Creak
inless chamers wa these Souls will not be
displaced take that it's like Ghostbusters
come with me to see your wife this is your last
chance to tell ala that you love her she already
knew she she
knows
no that awesome
wonder what the specific EX look so cool that was
so heartfelt and sweet too like the flashbacks
with her like was now him with reaching like
death it's like he knows she knew he loved
her like we couldn't do it without now die Danny
deito it's like the POV is exactly like the r and
I love it he got to the Sea's getting
to the Sea they yeah pH kept their
promise you have allowed the
ghost to commit theft oh so
pretty what's this you got says Alissa or
something will that's way better ghost wink it's
a ghost wink and a ghost sweet I was voted as vice
president of my class whoa you climbed the ranks
of friendship and popularity that's a 180 before
you step inside this could change the course
of your entire life that's a risk I'm willing
to take kiss [Music] her bra shot [Music] out
ah why did they do like you know a walkthrough
like they do for stranger things but it should
have been for this movie like a walkthrough of
the Haunted Mansion why didn't you guys do that
it would have been a good idea oh I'm so mad now
that you okay now let's watch Yeti Murphy version
I have not seen that I have not seen the Eddie
pery version I haven't seen it I wonder if it's
good yeah I was just getting some New Orleans
singing in style of singing I am not eating at all
today Tara I am so hungry me too I think we should
have a big meal and then continue this review oh
okay right after are you going to cook the meal
cuz I didn't bring food here and I got to be
here for a while so no no you can postm yourself
something something out of your own pocket yeah
all right I just thought maybe he'd cook me up
something nope no you know no we'll talk first
we can talk first so what' you think Tera I loved
it I thought it was really cute I loved uh I mean
I really like the kid I wish there was more of
him in it I liked the comedy the comedy and the
pacing of the tone everybody in this delivered on
that in that regard like it was all when it needed
to be funny it was I liked how the the lighting
with the ghosts the ghost always had a pink uh
Pink esque to them um there's a pinkes there's a
pink esque and uh the shots kept it really really
engaging but you know what's what was not bugging
me but I was like when is that handheld POV shot
going to come back from the beginning where
we're looking at a POV from the ghost point
of view with the people and it never did um I
don't mind that I just thought they could play
with that more um but I do like how heartfelt and
sweet it was there was great messages in here of
like especially when he's speaking to the kid of
like your dad loves you and he wants you to see
you thrive and be happy um you know the kid needed
to let his dad go in a sense at the same time that
our lead needed to let go of his wife right and
and I guess grieve that more and know that she
knew that he loved her right um which was nice I
think there was just and I like that they didn't
because we caught that vibe in the beginning of
him and Rosario that they're like oh you're going
to become a nice happy family and instead it made
it all of them which I think is way better to not
sure there's a vibe there at the end but to not
show it I like it so much more yeah yeah damn
that is a glowing glowing review wow he called it
glowing that was that was a that was a high praise
review right there wow High pra summation of your
thoughts there happy to hear it um some stuff kind
of fluctuates for me I'm not as a high here as you
are however I I I see this through two different
lenses here one is the Target demographic well
there's kind of like a couple of camps of a Target
demographic I would say there's ones who love
obsessed with the ride I I love the ride I do I
think it's like my favorite thing the last time
I went to Disneyland it was shut down it's like
it's really common for that ride to be shut down
it's a real pain in the it's always like stay in
your buggy I wish I knew the message I it's shut
down constantly I'm like what the hell's going on
with this ride but then you whenever you go on it
you're like looks like there's a lot of work that
goes into keeping this ride operational you know
um but it's really and they it's even cooler when
it's Halloween time they make it all Nightmare
Before Christmas I love that ride I really do
um I wonder what it's like in Universal Studios
or Orlando uh Universal Disney World Universal
Disney World Universal stud yes because the room
where this the sance with the four chairs where
they were like initially beginning I that does not
look totally like the Sans room in Disneyland but
I was because the walls look very different and I
was like does that room is that what it looks like
in Disney World because people say the rides are
larger and longer there so I don't know could be
yeah yeah um I often hear that about many things
yeah that it was larger and longer yeah yeah
you're not the first woman to say that sentiment
to me mhm yeah I'm sure not I'm sure plenty have
said it which is why you settle down you're like
snag it quick CU if the word gets out you know
gonna be let me tell you it's really easy to have
a disappointed wife around town you know what I
mean yeah so anyway the kids movie Tera yeah well
be mindful you know that was spoken in metaphor
maybe we should watch the s anding around here and
you should know when to reel it in a little bit
all right to call me out on my stuff uh yeah cuz
there's that side and then there's also the main
demographic which is like the family just it's
Disney and they want to be family accessible and I
think on that on that front because I I think like
a movie like Pirates of the Caribbean 2 is harsher
in terms of this is real perilous this is real
spooky scary like that one is like really intense
and scary and maybe not as like family accessible
Pirates 2 I'm talking about specifically where
this more so goes to the camp of wanting to be
more into like a pirates one I would say where
you're like it's not exactly scary but it's got
some of that spooky ghost Vibe and whatever um
so in terms of like a familyfriendly accessible
Halloween type of Adventure I I think that it's
pretty damn great I think it's really really great
in that realm because they bring a lot of the like
the set design the art Direction just the overall
production the the makeup I thought was great and
the and there's a lot of inventiveness and a lot
of vivid creativeness when it comes to keeping
like the dark aesthetic but having it be it it
feels like a really elevated Disney Channel movie
yeah you know what I mean yeah like okay this
is above and beyond Disney Channel uh but it's
still it still really pops and it's vibrant and
I love theith Stanfield a lot like for a leading
character he's very unique because he's very
despondent and he's not as like high energetic
yet he doesn't ever feel like he wants to ever
steal the show like he really cares to share the
screen and I I loved I loved him a lot and overall
that I think the Journey of grief and acceptance
is a great thing to constantly it's kind of in
a lot of movies but I I I like how this sort of
leads with that there's there can be a beauty and
a and a bonding nature to be found in you know and
grief yeah the the parts of it that were kind
of like flip-flopping for me was honestly just
there's something about the there's something
about the pacing especially within the just
the the dialogue scenes themselves you notice it
mainly when When Tiffany hadish started speaking
in the house as like getting into the next realm
right you were like her tone is weird but I don't
know if you just meant her if you meant when it
started there it got a little off kilter I meant
kind of like with like and it wasn't so much in
like the first 20 to 30 minutes but the movie is
2 hours and I and I think in a lot of it there was
some type of strange way the pacing and the Rhythm
was done when it wasn't a spooky intended type of
scene when it was just them kind of going back and
forth and around the table like there like part of
the editing would feel a little would feel off to
me and that the way those scenes would Breathe
would feel too long of a breath I don't no I
actually feel too short I think I think there was
like uh there there was a something that felt kind
of Curt about the way a lot of things were kind of
uh done and it kind of just get wrapped up really
I'm not not exactly sure it's sleep deprived and
really hungry but I know how I feel and I got to
get that feeling communicated properly it's one
of those challenges that I'm doing right now it
feels like it's like quippy dialogue but it wasn't
quippy dialogue it's like they're trying to do it
in the edit yeah yeah there's like a a lack of an
energy to me that I wasn't quite feeling because
I think as individual performers everyone is like
well C like everyone was well cast for the roles
that they got and obviously the weight was given
primarily the substance to like Keith Stanfield
and the little boy which is arguably where the
weight of the performances really have to go to
where everyone else kind of felt um you know the
word is not Bland because I think the C the actors
themselves provided a a personality for them it
was a little two-dimensional when I think like
two you know what I mean yeah I do I feel like
the scene with Owen Wilson and the ghost at the
end had that right kind of like cuz it was just
him with their responses and that felt more like
in the realm to me I don't know why oh really
okay see that's where I think we're differing
because I was I wasn't really clicking with with
some of that stuff and especially at the very end
in the big finale I did I did feel that with the
way the sound design was done that a lot of it
felt like they were fixing a lot of this in post
and I didn't really feel the physicality of the
emotion in the voice the perform perform yeah
was like this weird hodge podge stuff and just
overall the the rhythm of a lot of the scenes and
maybe it was just like the comedy itself wasn't
particularly working for me yeah but the but the
thing is I don't I like while I don't love a lot
of the scenes and there wasn't spooky stuff
happening the thing I showed up for was that
stuff yeah and I really enjoyed that you know so
that's why I would still give the movie at least
on my end I would still give it like a 7 to a 7.5
because the things I wanted to work before hitting
play on this really worked for me yeah um like the
homages to the ride I thought they worked in the
the ride elements very well uh to the point that
even if you don't know the ride it's it doesn't
distract you like like You' feel left out or some
[__] right that worked really well um all the
Aesthetics of it I like to me the real stars of
this movie was the way this the cinematography
was was done and in those horror scenes and also
just the the visual language of pretty much all of
that I thought was really great and the when
they would they use like animation blends to
enhance other flashback stuff but yeah it's like
you got a you got an ensemble of characters and I
only really cared about one person yeah you know
were two people and even like Rosario Dawson as
grieving wife maybe it was an intentional thing
but kind of felt like she was just kind of like
charismatically chipper for for most of it and
like I'm a little stressed but I didn't really
feel like the weight of her performance right you
know right yeah I didn't feel that either so that
was that was probably the part like when you're
reading the cast list in the beginning like oh
we're going to get a real Ensemble here but for
some reason a lot of it was just feeling kind
of flat to me instead of really singing when I'm
like a you got a real Ensemble here and I think a
lot of that should have really saying hi but like
I said I think the things that I saw Snippets of
over my shoulder when an ad was playing I I never
actually watched like a trailer from beginning to
end but the things I saw like little bits of and
uh for the Halloween spooky season time the the
things I really I'm not just saying it to be nice
like those are the things that really worked for
me strongly yeah and so for me I would definitely
still say I liked it and i' recommend it because
this is the kind of movie that you can put on
for the family at Halloween time and still really
enjoy yeah totally I mean that you can play for
kids but adults also won't be like totally bored
out of their minds right I also don't know that
the movie needed to be two hours I I'm like I I
wonder if if it was you know an hour and 30 and
would have moved faster that it if it would have
you know you know when movies can they move quick
where you're like whoa that was great because it
just felt like it was there and then it was gone
um I don't know if that would have helped it a
little bit but um yeah yeah I mean I I I'll give
it like I'll give it an eight out of 10 because
I is this this one 84% damn really I mean it's
got 84% audience score which is like yeah that's
great Tomato Meter is no go but the Tomato meters
37% and I could not be further off with that all
like I there's no way I would give it that wow
yeah what is the what is the the idea here why
everyone's only everyone's upset about this this
fil oh it's saying it's play playing it even safer
than its 2003 representation and I don't can't
make a reference to that um um yeah okay yeah
that the that one the rules one right I guess I
don't know I yeah I I I know what I didn't really
care for uh which was I I didn't really feel the
chemistry of The Ensemble as much as I wanted to
and I didn't really and I thought there was some
very weird editing choices in in those scenes but
I think for a paranormal good time I I thought it
was I thought it was really fun right I thought a
lot of that was really fun it's okay I could not
be more I had no idea the reviews were this bad
it's it's it's kind of surprising yeah it's weird
and I'm like there's one that says they don't
we don't know where the ghosts come from and so
everyone is confused and I'm like well if you've
ridden the ride if you've been on the ride and you
know The Haunted Mansion you kind of know where
the ghosts come from yeah so we don't need that
background sure if someone's like coming in uh you
know as a blank slate which why have you not been
to Disneyland before and why are you watching this
movie but I'm just saying uh I wasn't confused
I mean they did explain that that guy was stuck
but whatever uh I guess people people really this
is so I am surprised by the negative feedback uh
like like just how negative it is you know yeah
diffuses any potential scares with a hot color
pink palette I did bring that up um I don't think
that diffused it I think there was I think there
was one point when um he's walking up on his wife
and he goes like Alyssa he calls to her that I'm
like oh why didn't that scare me when she turns
around and smiles and it looks creepy and I'm like
oh they had laid on that shot in silence a little
bit longer Alyssa waited waited and then it kind
of comes around but it's like too fast where it's
like yeah they're diffusing it so it's we're not
building up all this like tension see I that's
where I feel like the movie at times was kind of
at odds with itself too fast right like it didn't
allow the it didn't know if like we wanted it I
felt like they would actually wanted to be more
horror and wanted to be scarier and then they
had to do things things to dial it back because
they can't because CU you can't be that scary you
know but I think the movie actually wanted to
go that far um kind of like how amlin back in
the day would have done it or even like we just
saw Monster House you know like and even though
it's an animated movie I would still liking that
to oh it's a it's a it's a family horror movie and
that one would like they'd go there they they do
and I think this movie wanted to go there and it
wanted to have have a little bit more of a mature
element to it as well especially when you have
our main character dealing with the death of his
wife I think the movie was at odds with itself at
times in terms of what tone do we strike yeah
I think tonal CU like the tone was not quite I
didn't really get a sense of like an atmosphere or
a specific tone during this during this experience
yeah you know and I think that was the part of
it that was kind of missing for me CU where I
could feel where it could be at odds throughout
a lot of the journey yet though I I still think
I still feel like I saw I was able to watch this
from well what audience are they targeting and
then from from being able to sit in that seat I I
was able to really enjoy it oh yeah yeah you know
still like super super fun and I'm like they did
have the ability to make those moments last longer
and make them scarier and more of a like ah but
there was still smaller moments that was like oh
that was spooky which was fun and still very again
family friendly yeah kind of like 37% is really
harsh I don't know where these people are from
or what they're doing but like like one just says
cannot be counted as anything more than a missed
opportunity but get this he works for Pittsburgh
magazine and I'm like you probably haven't been to
Disneyland because if you have and you've you've
been on the ride there's just so many like Easter
eggs in here and they they incorporate it so well
and I'm like do these people think that like this
is not based off of a ride yeah like are they just
like oh we're pulling it from thin air and they
could have made a story a lot better I'm like
they're incorporating a ride that people adore
and love and there's only so much EB and flow
that you can do in regards to story when you're
also attaching it to a ride like they did story
with the lead guy and the kid and like letting go
of grief and all of that but that headless guy is
in the in the ride before you get like they're
in there's there's certain things they got to
follow and I feel like some of these people
are like I don't know they're not Disneyland
fans and they don't get it I don't know and feel
you on that I I think too is in terms of how they
Incorporated that stuff from the ride was just
really great so good I think they did it great
and and um I'm I am I am it's weird like I okay
with the criticisms about like I scroll through
some of these criticisms but I just feel I guess
I feel like just the pros outweigh the cons for me
yeah AB absolutely I feel the cons like a lot of
the cons are about kind of the things I was just
saying like I think the P some the pacing is a
little weird yeah and and uh yeah the performances
fall like in this weird camp where it's not like
it is the energy that can feel flat of of certain
moments but the things that work just really shine
like it was is visually really appealing and it
it speaks to the sensibilities of things that I
personally enjoy watching um so yeah I had fun I
had fun I don't I do not regret my experience and
I could see this being a great Halloween movie to
watch every year I think it's a really fun movie
thank yeah and I think if you're a fan of the ride
yeah it's really enjoyable but yeah guys what did
you think about it leave your thoughts down below
be sure to subscribe leave a like Tara thanks for
helping me uh enjoy more of this spooky Halloween
season spooky and yo homie homie will you help
me shout out someone yeah all right man I think
you will let me just make sure your your next
person isn't here all right you're good you're
good to go what do we got what do we got Tara Tara
always says my name wrong CZ he thinks it's funny
do I I don't know sometimes I do okay no no nope
all right we got a shout out okay let's do it we
gotta shout out Michael B Michael B Jordan he's
missing the Jordan at the end but it's all right
because I don't even like no that's a lie I do
like Michael B Jordan but I like Michael B too
I don't know anything about you why don't you tell
me too well Michael B has a YouTube channel called
omn media wow he does reactions he's great and I
think based off the upload schedule I devised his
video that he just shot with John he lives in
Virginia oh so he had to film remotely wow um
that he shot with John was mission Impossible dead
reckoning oh and I think that went up yesterday
cool so go and he did reactions to all the mission
impossible his an impossible Tom Cruz for life
baby yeah cult yeah and uh I'm in it happy to be
he's a great guy and um he he gets just as much
sleep as me usually so we have a lot in common I
love that you like Tom Cruz too because so do I
that's the end of my rap Michael B I don't need
to RH you rapping or were you just saying words
in a rhythm that sounded like it was a rap both
I was doing a combo you're welcome it's easy to
just put your words in a type is it because I find
you struggling right now I find you struggling to
do it okay hey you want a peanut butter sandwich
before you film again cuz he's going to cook me
something I'll make I'll make you a peanut
butter sandwich I I am so hungry I've tried
hiding my Hunger but I have like no water and no
and I'm like what did I do to myself I need to
drink more water weird time to film a 2hour thing
and be like be sharp Greg not today not today but
honest honest Always Love You So Much comment
tell us how cool we are bye okay [Music] bye